yeah a round of applause as we await
lift off spacex's next private flight to
the International Space Station waiting
to take off
it looks like the weather is playing
ball the passengers include Saudi
Arabia's first astronauts in decades and
a U.S businessman who started his own
sports car racing team let's listen in
50 minus 10. nine eight seven six five
four three two one engines full power
and liftoff
together we expand what is possible in
low earth orbit add Astra and Godspeed
ax2
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
plus 30 seconds into this historic
t plus 36 second 36 seconds into flight
a great view of Falcon 9 heading to
space
power Telemetry nominal we're into the
throttle bucket is the first stage is
Throttle Down power on the Merlin
engines in preparation for Max Q
Falcon 9 is supersonic
faster than the speed of sound as we're
getting great views from the first stage
camera looking back at Kennedy Space
Center complex 39a
one throttle up
out of the throttle bucket there's one
Bravo
copy one Bravo we're in full power and
that call out one Brahma that's another
one of those abort modes as we get
higher and faster the logic for drug and
should a contingency occur changes from
stage to stage
chill announcement says we're getting
the turbo pump on the second stage
engine cooled down in preparation for
its light up coming up in just another
minute from now
again great views looking back and you
can see the contrail as we left 39a and
the uh the shadow of the contrail
against the cloud deck around Florida
now we're coming up three big sequences
and a view live of the crew inside
dragon
they're getting ready we're gonna get
three events here main engine cut off
and then we're gonna light the second
stage engine we've heard the throttle
down in preparation for stage separation
Pico
State separation confirmed
copy two outputs
and back ignition
stage one who's back startup
all right Steve separation we've lit the
second stage engine the first stage is
into the Boost back burn working its way
back towards Cape Canaveral
views on the left side that's the first
stage engines running as we come back to
the launch site or the landing site
second stage engine nozzle is visible on
the right side as we're powering the
Axiom 2 crew into low earth orbit on the
way to the International Space Station
waiting for call out that the Boost back
burn is complete
stage one boost back shut down
right on time first stage completed the
first of three Burns heading back to the
landing site
second stage continuing on Power and on
trajectory
acquisition Casino Bermuda
we head Northeast the Bermuda ground
station SpaceX trajectory nominal
Bermuda is listening into the vehicle
nominal trajectory
and the crew here's the call out of a
so four minutes into flight everything
continuing to go well first days heading
back and there's the crew on the second
stage getting the right into orbit to
the space station
coming up we're waiting for the next
trajectory call out from the guidance
officer Dragon SpaceX trajectory nominal
ah love to hear those words a nominal
trajectory for Dragons nominal
trajectory
and maybe even a little bit of
excitement in the crew's voice
Commander Peggy Whitson calling back
down hearing that call out from GNC of a
nominal trajectory
left side of the screen you can see the
first so spacex's latest private flight
to the International Space Station has
successfully taken off amongst the four
crew the first Arab woman in space where
Anna benawi from Saudi Arabia she said
before liftoff I'm very honored and
happy to be representing all the dreams
and all the hopes of all the people in
Saudi Arabia and all the women back home
the crew Dragon capsule which is a fully
autonomous is expected to dock with the
space station early tomorrow with its
passengers joining Seven astronauts
already on board the orbiting laboratory
that will be following this progress
closely